c'est vrai que parfois dans les
magazines on voit d une qui ne
correspond pas du tout à ce qui est la
règle et regardez là une de sophie
davant
sophie davant frappé par la maladie
c'était quoi l'histoire finalement un
rhume la marine exactement l'avait juste
un rhume non sophie davant avait été
très vénérés contre 7 une avait poussé
un coup de gueule d'ailleurs sur les
réseaux sociaux
voilà frappé par là une voie là elle
avait juste un rhume sophie davant way
regardez autre exemple d'une sur ces
lignes ont regardé elle se bat contre la
ligne
qu'est-ce qu'elle avait mis la photo est
terrible c'était rené c'est erroné à
l'abus rooney elle était militante pour
aider les gens qui étaient dans l
alcoolisme et sa non pas du tout son
père elle explique simplement que son
père aurait bu donc on le fait elle fait
attention
voilà c'est ton père voir graphe ses
tubes war graves c'est annie cordy
c'est très grave annie cordy la une sera
ni commentaire agressé à coups de bâton
annie cordy
ah oui c'est vrai quévert quotidien pas
de pompage de l'eau grâce à des cordes
et je sais pas ce que je désire garder
une qu'ils avaient faite sur emmanuel
macron regarder emmanuel macron ils
divorcent divorce avec brigitte mâcon et
c'était quoi le thé qua non il venait de
démissionner du gouvernement à l'époque
ouais ouais regardez michel drucker il
va mourir
c'est chaud ça casse est désespérée de
son médecin le diagnostic désespérée de
son médecin peut pas l'interdire ça on
aurait continué papier ils sont tourné
de telle sorte que ce sont inattaquables
quittera alors le truc est pourquoi ils
ont mis michel drucker va mourir qu'on
embrasse michel bien sûr qu'il allait
mourir danse sur un plateau non son
médecin a simplement dit qu'il avait
toujours besoin d'être actif mais qu'il
allait finir par mourir un jour comme
tout le monde
alors eh bien sûr celle qu'on a souvent
vu aussi mimi mathy piétiner au public
cette affaire ça va ça alors gressard
sets acharnés de son agresseur s'est
acharné devant des témoins regarder ce
qui met ces luttes en fait un comics et
stéphane guillon qui avait fait une
vanne sur elle en spectacle l'autre
julie gayet et julie gayet une terrible
dépendance
voilà depuis 20 ans de vie 25 ans un peu
plus s'en passer c'est quoi oui oui le
plus violent le public des croissants et
croissants public bravo kevin non elle
avait dit qu'elle mettait toujours une
boîte d'aspirine dans son sac
julie gayet pour vous dire c'est à coire
mais je vous dis c'est fou oui le seul
truc qui me gêne moi c'est que les gens
râlent quand ils sont sûrs mais quand
ils sont pas une qui vont prendre le
train qui le voit ils l'achètent afin de
savoir s'ils ont aussi au boycott
si on n'est pas content on n'achète pas
ce magazine or plein de gens achètent
non mais t'es comme les gens qui râlent
contre voici ils sont les premiers à
acheter aussi voici les gens disaient
mais personne n'y voit si ça peu plus
d'un million franchement donc voila moi
ça m'énerve ça ne savait qu'on avait une
chance valérie bénaïm également regarder
d'en réussir est regardé c'était dans
télé loisirs
valérie bénaïm présente son nouveau
compagnon s'est trouvée on s'est
reconnus on s'est aimés immédiatement
teysseyré barrère gars des aurès et
patoche regardez comme il est beau
pathos et parler de votre série ah oui
parler de votre chien mais non c'était
pas du tout fan non c'est pas du tout
une bonne c'était vrai c'était comme ça
et parler du chien de valérie benaïm
soit c'est plutôt marrant c'est en tout
cas une bonne tête
qu'est ce qu'il ya le chien en tout cas
une bonne je savais pas de coiffeur de
30 ans à l'échec